ah oui oui mais justement je vous ai
déjà dit que moi j'aime parler toujours
des choses qui m'intéressent le plus
mettre en sécurité
et alors je vais vous dire que je vais
commencer pour parler du libre un ordre
de mes goûts et mes préférences des
livres que j'en ai fait 35 d'imaginer de
6,35 vivre celui que je trouve le plus
admirable parce qu'il correspond
absolument à toutes mes pensées la rue
pieusement respectée dans le moindre
détail musulin rempli d'informations
c'est un livre qui s'appelle virer cette
d'immortalité
après il ya le livre de visages cachés
duquel vous reparler dans le cas où
c'est un récit de monsieur andré
parinaud que ce ton glane amis et trade
alignant presque 3 kg de sel
possiblement et lesquelles tout ce qu'il
dit dans son livre sur sa propre et
unique responsabilité
et je marque
on va leur en prit car ce n'est pas tout
je ne suis pas arrivé je ne paie pas de
mine avec m'annonçait moustache et
vallonné de free ne viser qu'un il
fallait juger d'avis quand il faisait de
la peinture
il faisait de la littérature se
répondent et quand je faisais dans l'art
de la littérature je faisais dans notre
monde peinture donc chacun doit tôt ou
tard fatalement venir à moi la preuve
pour bouger de là
là
ce texte résume en deux pages toute la
miss pic gastronomie dali mienne je vous
remercie